it's the evening of February 1st 2024
it's hard to believe we're already a
month into this new year so it's time
for another monthly update video where
I'll tell you about what went on in
January and what we've got coming up in
February I always like to begin by
highlighting three big things and
actually I had a huge selection of
things so I'm pairing it down to just
the three that I most want to put on
your radar so one of these is I just
opened up enrollment tonight for my next
online class people are always saying oh
I want to take classes with you this is
your actual opportunity it's a six week
online class on stoicism and the
cardinal virtues I'll tell you about
that in just a little bit the second big
thing has to do with worlds of
speculative fiction and we're doing
something a little bit different this
month so I am doing uh the session on
James Kennedy's two novels dare to know
and Bride of the tornado and I was able
to do an interview with him today so
there's going to be some clips of there
in that and he is going to join us for
the actual session so first time that we
have an author coming on and being part
of Worlds of speculative fiction third
big thing you may have seen or you may
have already been sent I now have a
substack newsletter which I'll be using
for other things like posting resources
and putting notes but I'm going to be
doing a monthly newsletter so if you've
put yourself on the list for that years
ago or a month ago and you're like where
is it it's now going out so that's kind
of a big thing for me so let's now talk
about
January January was a pretty busy month
courses started both academic and in my
study with Sadler Academy I'm teaching
two online courses from Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design one is a
religions of the world class the other
is existentialist philosophy and
literature and I also started my 10 week
online open enrollment Phil ancient
philosophers on friendship we actually
had our second class session today which
went quite well um I had a lot of events
that I was participating in I did my
usual AMA that's ask me anything session
worlds of speculative fiction this month
we did um a session on the third and
fourth books in Steven Erikson's mozon
book of the Fallen a lot of people into
that including myself we had another
really cool um heavy classic heavy metal
class and this time we brought a friend
on board to talk about the new wave of
British heavy metal so Scott and I got
to geek out with our friend Kenneth from
Britain who actually lived through that
era and then we had our understanding
anger class as well we focused on some
more Greek tragedy anger in sophocles's
uh Ajax and in uid Meda so that was a
lot of fun I also did quite a bit of
volunteering at almost home cat rescue I
did a lot of writing here and there some
of it academic some of it in my medium
blog and I started that substack
newsletter so if you're interested in
that you can see the link to all these
things below uh you click show more or
video description and uh you'll find the
substack if you want to get in on it uh
I'll be publishing a lot of things there
in the coming months I also did an
interview with everyday stoic and uh
that went quite well and and you know
you can check out the link to that below
as well I did a lot of video work this
last month including publishing two
interviews in the ideas that matter
series one with Helen de Cruz and the
other with Usha Nathan two uh people who
I I like quite a bit uh book reviews I
did a very positive book review on
Darius uh kala's book on Ancient uh
philosophy and early Christianity and I
did a
rather what would you call it not quite
scathing but certainly negative review
of a book that was sent to be by St
Martin press called the essential stoic
you can see the link to that below it
was so harsh that it actually got turned
into a meme which you can easily find I
think just putting it into Google I also
did something kind of unusual so years
and years and years ago I shot video of
me playing banjo and singing in my old
apartment in fville so we're talking
like 12 13 years ago so I dug up those
old videos and and I said should I put
these out there I did a poll and people
said yeah put them out there can't hurt
so I you know fixed the sound a little
bit fix the lighting as best as I could
and I put four of them out there they're
all me playing cover songs of cracker
Johnny Cash motohead you know things
like that and I did a lot of core
concept videos I finished up the series
on a Manu con pra to any future
metaphysics which you know happy to do
so I also did a lot of odds and ends
things I I did one on Martin Luther
King's unfulfilled hopes I did one on
Thomas Hobs leviathon one on William
James the will to believe uh certain KAG
guards the present age one on shest love
shestov all things are possible and uh
another one on rila's letters to a young
poet and a lot of these were sort of
things that were left behind from when I
did series before and I didn't get to
all the videos so I got a lot of those
sort of things off my desktop docket
whatever you want to call it and then I
did some videos on senica and letters
that I hadn't gotten to before um I also
did a couple Saddler stories one about a
play that I acted in actually wrote as a
kid about going in the Army the very
first day um I did a quick takes um on
whether you need to study philosophy in
a chronological manner or whe whether
that's even really possible and a lot of
people enjoyed that and then I did a lot
of podcasting work as
well um I finished up Alistair
McIntyre's how to appear virtuous
without really being so which is a great
piece uh I did several on silica mold
and her fellow uh writers on uh feminist
corporate governance and then I did a
oneoff on
uh gems NK gon's really great short
story those who stay and fight and then
I switched to Plato's Republic did some
uh work on Republic book 10 and the
discussion of you know artists and and
Artisans and then I did a whole sequence
on Aristotle's Poetics so that that's
what got accomplished in January um lot
of behind the scenes kind of work some
of which you're going to see this coming
month so that's a great segue into
talking about that we've got a lot of
really fun stuff coming up this month of
February now all the times that I'm
going to give you are central time so
you might want to check your time zone
so you're not showing up early or late
or something like that if you're not in
Central Time We Begin this weekend with
the monthly AMA that's ask me anything
uh session where it's exactly that
people ask me questions about philosophy
about personal development about what I
think about politics music personal
things all sorts of interesting matters
we follow that up with a philosophy chat
for my patreon supporters which is kind
of a perk for them if you're interested
in that you can easily see how to sign
up for patreon below uh a week later on
Saturday the 10th at noon we'll be
having the next understanding anger and
this time we're moving back from Greek
tragedy into philosophy we are going to
be looking at the epicurian and what
they have to say about the emotion of
anger which actually turns out to be a
good bit and is quite
interesting on the 14th uh that's a
local event here in the greater
Milwaukee area at the Frank wenberg
Library we kick off the quarterly series
philosophers in the midst of history uh
on on the uh 14th at 6:00 p.m. with a
talk about senica and how he figures
into history the influence that he had
all sorts of other cool stuff about this
great stoic philosopher on the 17th uh
Scott truli will be joining me again for
classic metal class and this time we're
going to be talking about uh Japan and
heavy metal so we're going to be talking
about ja Japanese bands from flower
traveling band all the way into the
1980s so bands like loudness for example
but we're also going to be talking about
the phenomenon of being Big in Japan and
how Japan provided a context for so many
bands to make enough money to stay
afloat to tour to get some really really
great Albums Live albums out there so
that's going to be a really fun session
um I will put put some uh stuff out
later this month about how you can join
us for that session and uh participate
if you'd like to um on the 18th I will
be finally getting around to something
that I didn't get to last month and I
know I promised to do that which is
another one of our my you know advice
for self-directed study emmanu K how to
study him so that'll be happening at 2:
pm. on the 18th on the
uh 24th at 10:00 a.m. we will be kicking
off our online class link to it is below
stoicism and the cardinal virtues it's a
six- week class I'll tell you a little
bit about that in just a bit because I
do want to finish this part up on the
24th at noon then we will have worlds of
speculative fiction where we're going to
have some clips from James Kennedy
talking about those two great novels
and after that in the zoom conversation
we will be joined by James Kennedy and
he said he's really looking forward to
it so let's not disappoint him I suppose
right so all of that's going on um as I
mentioned before you know I've got a
substack now I'm going to be doing more
writing in that and also writing on
medium as well and I'm working on some
academic pieces with some collaborators
uh I've got some other things that I'm
doing helping to plan out events I'm
going to be helping Harold cley uh in
organizing the annual stoicon this year
there's another conference that I'm also
working on and I'm on an American
philosophical
Association uh committee for the mid for
the Central Division 2025 which will be
an online conference so I'm helping out
with that as well um got my classes
going on so both in the study with
Sadler Academy and my academic classes
that keeps me pretty occupied and it's
fun to be in the virtual
classroom but I should tell you about
this um stoicism and the cardinal
virtues classes so starting you know at
the end of of February if you want to
understand what the stoics actually mean
by these four cardinal virtues wisdom
Justice courage Temperance there's a lot
of stoic texts a lot of stoic thinkers
that talk about it you got to kind of
piece the stuff together I have been
doing that for years in my classes in my
writings I'm going to be leading
students through that so it's a really
wonderful opportunity to get to uh
engage with some stoic thinkers and
texts and really wrap your head around
this absolutely Central Doctrine within
stoicism that virtue is either the only
good or it's one of the uh major genuine
Goods depends on which stoic you ask so
that'll be coming up soon as well uh
what else do we got going on video work
I got a lot of core concept videos to
shoot I mentioned I've started shooting
some videos on senica I've got more of
those to put out and to shoot I also
have a commissioned video on jel Delo uh
and and uh guitari anti attius that I'm
G to be putting out as well having to do
with the body without organs um I've got
a one-off on
dostoevsky's um uh Brothers K maof that
I need to shoot once I actually get my
hand on on the book that I've requested
from the library it's a particular
translation I want and I've got some uh
videos to shoot on France
Fon uh black skin white masks and I've
got some stuff to shoot on uh France
Kafka both from the trial and
from uh the metamorphosis so I'm going
to have a lot of stuff coming out on
that um I've got some more Sadler
stories videos that I want to shoot you
know telling you about my my life my
memories I also found some old footage
of a talk that I gave on the Christian
philosophy debates back in 2011 when my
book just came out and I've put put that
together fixed up the sound a bit as
much as I could and I'll be putting that
out for the public to check out you know
uh you'll notice I look quite a bit
different back then um what else book
reviews I've got some more book reviews
in the works I've got some ideas that
matter interviews I'm doing quite a few
of them this month and in the coming
months and those are really quite a lot
of fun I do have something that I'd kind
of like to get your take so I have one
more Greg plays the banjo and sings
cover tunes video to put out should I
keep doing them should I shoot some more
of those with the songs that I
particularly like they're not going to
be old timey or Bluegrass stuff because
that isn't what I play I'm Into You know
a lot of rock artists and alternative
and metal and pop songs and stuff like
that so you know do you want to hear the
Scorpions on Banjo or motohead or Duran
Duran or the Cure or John Cougar melon
camp or you know all these different
other bands more cracker if so you know
I'm game to do that I need to put in
some practice I think so I don't know if
I'll get that out this month if people
want it but we'll see you know we'll see
uh podcast work um I've got some uh
episodes on John Cassie that I've
already released to my patreon
supporters and um you know those are
going to be coming out quite soon I've
also got some uh Sadler shorts these are
you know little things where I take a a
passage from a book and then you know
give a little reflection about it that
ties into your uh daily life or you know
our relationships or stuff like that so
I've got some of those down the line and
I've started work on editing
podcast episodes on Philip K dicks do
Android's Dream of Electric Sheep one of
my favorite dick stories not the
favorite actually my favorite a little
bit of trivia here uh used to be man in
the High Castle it's it's become uh A
Scanner Darkly but you it could always
change right so I've got that coming out
as well so a lot of stuff going on this
month we're lucky that it's a leap year
and we get 29 days uh still a short
month we'll see how much of this I can
actually
accomplish um you know sometimes I say
I'm going to get more done than I
actually do but I get a lot of stuff
done so I hope you can join me for some
of these online events think about
enrolling in the uh stoicism and the
cardinal virtues class if you have any
interest in that it's going to be a
great class A lot of learning is going
to be taking place every time that I
teach I really put a lot of work work
into it and people get a lot out of it
so um yeah see if you can join me and if
you're in the Milwaukee area if you can
make it to philosophers in the midst of
History come to it and uh introduce
yourself to me I always like meeting
people who are interested in philosophy
and uh I'll just wrap up here hope that
you have a great month ahead and I will
see you all somewhere in the
interwebs